all right so this week in what's a shame
Pat we could actually do it this week in
police brutality there are two videos
that we found online one coming out of
Columbus Ohio of a of a black man under
arrest
he's already been subdued and a police
officer comes later and kicks him in the
face and then we found a video from
Atlanta from Gwinnett County Georgia
rather basically the same thing we have
a black man on the ground handcuffed
subdued and a second officer comes into
the scene and kicks them in the faces
it's like standard operating procedure
now for the first 20 seconds or so that
you watch you think well maybe they're
being a little aggressive they're on
that round though nothing too major and
then someone else comes and kicks them
in the head right it's completely absurd
so instead of us talking about it let's
play the video let's Wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
so I mean what do you what you say okay
so let's give the facts that's all I can
really say at this point so this is the
gentleman the white and I use that term
loosely the officer and the white shirt
his name is Zachary Rosen of the
Columbus Ohio Police Department if you
recognize the name Zachary Rosen
he was just cleared by a grand jury
last month I believe yeah he was just
cleared in the shooting death of another
black man Henry Green and you know not
that one case has anything to do with
the other
clearly not directly but if you see this
guy what's his name again I don't want
to call him out of the wrong name I
don't want to use any superlatives to
call him Zachary Rosen comes running in
on the scene the man has already subdued
under arrest and being relatively
cooperative and he kicks the man in the
face that shows me the type of person a
character Zachary Rosen is at least in
this case the Columbus and I say at
least because we'll have to see what
happens but the Columbus Police
Department issued a statement saying
that officer Zachary Rosen is
investigation for his actions that took
place involving a suspect under arrest
on Saturday April 8th 28th 2017 so at
least he's under investigation in many
cases it won't even go to an
investigation and had there not been a
video no one would have said anything
there were other officers around there
who looked just complicit like they were
okay with this and even sometimes when
it goes to trial the jury just will
refuse to convict the police officers
because they take their word over any
other citizen and that's something that
you should probably disclose before
you're put on the jury right what they
don't do it they don't do it and they
slide in and this is what we saw and I
believe I forgot which state that was in
but that was a specific example North
Carolina with the shooting of a man who
was running away yeah they got shot time
back eight times in the back and they
couldn't convict them so many Walter
Scott Walter Scott is the name of the
victim and and that's exactly what
happened in the jury pool so you know
either it's irrelevant at this point
what this guy did on the ground what he
did he could be guilty of I don't care
what he's guilty of he's under arrest so
what he's done is irrelevant take him to
jail send the trial send him to jail all
of that is is completely irrelevant
what's relevant in this video is the
fact that he's on his hand coffee
subdued and here comes the police
officer to kick him in the face and the
exact same thing seems to have happened
in Gwinnett County Georgia let's take a
look at
[Music]
looks normal here right he's under here
comes another guy I mean seriously
he he is the demand on the ground for
those who listening to the podcast and
the radio show the man on the ground was
subdued enough for the arresting officer
to get off the ground and begin to radio
someone so right so he's comfortably
under arrest he doesn't look to be
resisting doesn't look to be doing
anything but he got called he's under
arrest the arresting officer stands up
begins to radio someone and this this
maniac out of nowhere runs to the scene
and stomps the man's head in the ground
and it's one thing if you're involved in
an altercation or the suspect is running
away and in the heat of the moment you
maybe go a bridge too far it's another
thing to have the suspect subdued on the
ground and come in later knowing that he
can't do anything his hands behind his
back and to kick him in the head like
that as if you're some sort of hero now
now here here's an example of these are
all examples of police losing their
minds right I'm trying to use much use
my words very carefully and precisely
here but the guy who we just watched get
his head stomp into the ground if you
look at his mug shot you can see his
nose as busted his face is busted up but
you want to know what he was arrested
for what he was charged with he was
charged with possessing less than one
ounce of marijuana and then obstructing
obstruction of a police officer and
several traffic citations so you know
basically if I don't know Georgia law
that well but they sell all like
misdemeanors and this is what he gets he
gets his head bashed into the ground and
whenever we do these types of stories I
always feel the need to give the caveat
that most police officers by and large
are upstanding individuals doing a great
job but they're also on the public
dollar they're also people that have to
be held accountable because we give them
a power that you can't just give to any
other citizen right and that's why
there's a lot of scrutiny and when
stories like this happen we have to pay
attention to it yeah I'm less prone to
give that caveat I used to give that
caveat and I understand why you would do
it I used to do it a lot but I'm just
tired of giving that caveat the reason
I'm tired to give that caveat is because
you know in reverse reverse
situation this is blanket accusation
that's placed on minorities you know you
know anything that happens with any
black person then Oh black lives matter
is guilty so everybody does this
generalization and blanket the blanket
accusations but more importantly they I
think it's wrong in both ends right yeah
I was gonna say more important than the
tit-for-tat is the need and the
necessity for police officers who are
good to step up to the plate and to
condemn this type of stuff instead of
sitting around idly and allowing it to
go on and the only time someone is held
accountable is when it's caught on video
so there may be a lot of good police
officers out there but they have to get
rid of the no snitch culture in the
police department